joining us now is dr celine gander who
served during the transition on then
president-elect biden's covet-19
advisory board she's an epidemiologist
and infectious disease expert at the nyu
grossman school of medicine and bellevue
hospital and host of the epidemic
podcast good morning good to see you
great to see you so presumably these
measures of the president is set to
announce do you agree with them and do
you think that they are enough
i do think we need to be tightening up
our recommendations and restrictions
around travel i think we should have
really tightened up that window for
testing
far
far earlier in the pandemic with the
emergence of the delta variant which has
a very short incubation period so i
think it's a move in the right direction
it's it's a little bit too late were you
surprised that this omicron variant
turned up in san francisco in california
in the united states even though we'd
only really just heard about it a couple
of days ago not really many of us were
assuming that it was already here if you
think about where are the big travel
hubs san francisco is one especially
with asia and other parts of africa and
california tests pretty aggressively for
the omicron variant so of course you're
not going to find something unless
you're looking for it so the delta
variant was 50 percent more contagious
than the alpha variant we don't know yet
how contagious or infectious omicron is
but can we just using the science assume
that it will be more so than delta
there are some worrisome signs that
we're seeing from south africa the slope
of increase was really dramatic in terms
of omicron cases that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's more
infectious but it points to the fact
that it could be
the case that was discovered in san
francisco fully vaccinated person
showing mild symptoms had received both
shots but not a booster what does that
tell you well one of the other concerns
we have about omicron is could it be
immune evading so that that could apply
to natural infection or vaccines we are
seeing people who had prior infection in
south africa being now reinfected with
omicron and the vaccines may be a little
bit less protective as was the case with
this person in san francisco against the
omicron variant so one of the questions
and you and i were talking about this
doctor the danger of future variants
as the virus bounces around the
population between unvaccinated and
vaccinated people how critical is it for
folks to get vaccinated because my
understanding based on the science is
that because we have so many people
unvaccinated that gives rise to future
variants well any time the virus has the
opportunity to spread from one person to
another it is replicating and it mutates
and some of those mutants will end up
being variants so we're really
increasing the odds the risk of a
variant emerging the more we allow the
virus to spread so vaccination is
certainly a way of reducing that risk of
new new variants so quickly before we go
10 seconds what do you recommend for
people to do as they gather for the
holidays get vaccinated get vaccinated
and if you haven't gotten a booster yet
get your booster all right dr celine
gounder as always thank you very much
appreciate it